cher nathalie dans notre grande série
des dégradés nous allons maintenant
passer commencer une mardi matin avec un
programme de constipation ballonnements
prestiti et maintenant ces minots ces
événements c'est la ménopause
quand on aime on ne compte pas voici
quelques conseils patricia jeu peut-on
cumuler chômage et bénévolat jusqu'au
bout je crois qu'en fait nous allons
passer à la rubrique juridique de roland
perez et puis nous irons sur patricia
enfin sur patricia nous y retournons
chez papa c'est vrai qu'on n'avait pas
une petite barre là moi j'ai une grosse
blind groupe
bon on sait qu'un ennemi est je crois
que ça va on essaie on essaie d
spontanée voyez-vous la spontanéité
voyez où ça mène